let's go next to
let's go to ricardo from oklahoma
yes hi can you hear me i can hear you
excellent excellent what a pleasure uh
what an honor actually pleasure um my
question to you is we talk a lot about
fake news
um
i want to
talk about social engineering do you
think fake news is social engineering
in what sense what in what way would it
be social engineering
so
fake news sounds very easy very uh
very simple you know somebody just posts
something fake online and it's fake news
social engineering has
a more
a deeper purpose you know has a strategy
behind it like right now on youtube you
can see
uh commercials of donald trump saying
that he's asking a lot of people to
vaccinate and all that but he's also
actually asking for money somewhere else
so to me that's um kind of like social
engineering trying to have people
believe he's
he's a good person asking for people to
vaccinate yet
uh
to me that's that that's a way to ask
for money and convince people to to get
money uh
you see what i'm saying so the the
definition of social engineering is
some kind of central plan to manage
social change and regulate the behavior
of a society
so the way that fake news could be
social engineering would be if one view
of fake news would be fake news spreads
really easily
and so it's profitable and so
individually all of these purveyors of
fake news put out fake news not to
influence society but just to make money
like that would be fake news not being
social engineering you could say fake
news with social engineering if there
was a concerted effort in order to
influence people to behave a certain way
on the basis of fake news that is being
spread so like you could say
maybe there's a social engineering
motivation for fake news spread about
the vaccine and that would be
to further some political goal or to
cause chaos at school board meetings or
whatever the case may be so sure i mean
in that sense
the coordinated spread of fake news
could be a form of social engineering i
don't know that we've we know that to be
the case necessarily
okay
i appreciate your time and your show
it's a great show great source of
information and knowledge and i
appreciate you taking my call thanks
ricardo i appreciate you calling in uh
interesting interesting uh for for sure